when I had zero dollars and zero cents I
woke up at six o'clock in the morning on
a Saturday and went garage sailing I
still believe to this day that the
biggest opportunity for somebody who has
five hundred dollars to their name is to
buy and sell things between Poshmark and
a thrift store and Craigslist at a
garage sale and a pawn shop and eBay I
got motivated to make that content to
help people and like now it's super fun
because my profile's grown that
content's done well so now when I garage
sale 10 people that are actively garage
selling as well somewhere in New Jersey
roll up on me and tell me their stories
and I learned a lot in garage sale